Elon Musk is famous for his Drive but
now he wants the rest of us to take our
hands off the wheel he's bringing out
fully self-driving Tesla's well at least
autonomous ready this isn't just a
software upgrade which is how Tesla has
updated its autonomous capabilities in
the past this is new hardware it
includes eight cameras for a full
360-degree view of the environment and
enhanced ultrasonic sensors as well as a
huge bump in computing power musk is
making typically big claims he says that
by the end of next year he'll
demonstrate a car that can drive from LA
to New York all without the driver or is
it a passenger by that point touching a
thing the full set of features will come
at a cost eight thousand dollars every
new car coming out for the company's
Fremont California factory from now on
will have the new hardware installed and
that includes the new cut-price model
three initially the cars will actually
be less capable than the first
generation vehicles features like Lane
Keeping adaptive cruise control which is
all autopilot really is won't be turned
on until probably December early buyers
are going to be guinea pigs their cars
will have to collectively accumulate
millions of miles with the human in
control and the computer running in the
background in shadow mode comparing what
it would have done to what the bag of
flesh does until the new hardware and
software is fully proven in addition to
training the system that will create a
digital trail which may show regulators
how many crashes the self-driving
functionality could have prevented they
of course may or may not put the kibosh
on masks autonomous ambitions Google's
been working on the same sort of
functionality since 2009 and yet still
hasn't cracked it so with this new
announcement Elon Musk has set himself
yet another crazy deadline to try to
meet
it's that much